[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
few stories in human history are as
gripping as the biblical tale of david
and goliath
most cultures have their own equivalent
in which a beleaguered people are saved
from the overwhelming force of evil at
the last moment by a well-aimed shot
from a young hero
hollywood regularly reinvents the tale
star wars harry potter lord of the rings
game of thrones
that's perhaps why people around the
world are rallying to the support of
ukraine's david
but the grim reality unfolding for
president zielenski's people is far from
the tale we tell our children
most of the time in most places the
story is one of suffering of loss
and of death
and then goliath wins
over the next 90 minutes we'll ask what
the rest of the world can do besides
ring its hands and discuss whether this
time hope can triumph over experience
with those calling shots here at home
and with testimony from those in the
line of fire including our colleagues
here at sky
the deputy prime minister dominic raab
will be here to tell us more about what
the government's planning to do to help
the people of ukraine
the shadow defense secretary john healey
will give us labor's view
what is what is it like for those living
in fear of russian attacks in ukraine's
towns and cities
kiev resident anastasia kriska will tell
us
air marshal philip osborne is a former
head of defense intelligence he'll tell
us what more he thinks britain could do
to help ukraine defend itself
former u.s ambassador to nato kurt
volker will tell us what he thinks the
alliance needs to do to thwart russian
aggression before it's too late
and i'll be talking to financial
security expert tom keating about
whether economic sanctions really will
make a difference
the cbi's chief economist rayne
newton-smith will give us her prediction
of the knock-on effects of the war on
the uk economy
and how far is beijing prepared to back
vladimir putin china expert junsun will
be here to tell us
and ruth smith ceo of index on
censorship will give us her thoughts on
the latest crackdown on press freedom in
russia
but first
dominic robb joins me now good morning
deputy prime minister good morning
what can you tell us this morning about
the state of the russian advance
particularly on the key cities of kiev
odessa and mario paul well of course uh
putin came in and had sold to the
russian people but also to his
conscripts on the ground in ukraine that
this would be far easier than it's
turned out that is partly a testament to
the resilience and the courage of the
ukrainian people and of course we've
been supporting them with uh training
through uh operation orbital which has
trained over 22 000 ukrainian armed
forces also the anti-tank missiles 2000
that we provided them and the wider
international community but they have
definitely proved
a tougher prospect than putin expected
and that has an effect on morale on the
russian side as well
of course at the same time we've imposed
the biggest sanctions package i can
remember
with
devastating consequences in terms of the
ruble falling to record low
the stock market and also we've seen the
russian central bank which itself has
been subject to sanctions doubling
interest rates that has put the squeeze
on putin what he's now doing is
responding with ever more brutal tactics
to try and rest back the initiative i
think the bottom line is none of the
major cities have yet fallen but i think
we are ought to be under no doubt that
our mission with our allies is to ensure
putin fails in ukraine and he's going to
take some time
we're talking about months if not years
and therefore we'll have to show uh some
strategic stamina because this is not
going to be over in days well let's
unpack some of that and let's deal with
some of the immediate issues the red
cross says that the russians have broken
the ceasefire by shelling civilians
this is actually your own professional
field as a
lawyer and you've prosecuted war
criminals um
this must be a war crime wasn't it
well you're right the the uh reckless
and uh frankly appalling tactics by the
putin regime
must be held to account not just putin
himself but also anyone taking illegal
orders and so on top of the 220 million
pounds of humanitarian support we're
providing uh to the ukrainian people
we're also very clear
that as the international criminal court
opens uh its examination of what's
taking place and it's right that a court
decides whether war crimes have been
committed we will provide the support
that diplomatic support we've been part
of the countries that have referred this
to the icc but also we've got a history
from nuremberg
onwards of supporting war crimes uh
prosecutions whether it's through
forensic evidence and or or right the
way through of course charles taylor um
radivan carriditcher here in
british jails and
uh we'll do whatever it takes we've got
a huge amount of experience i would also
just say it's part of what we do as a
country as a force for good you have a a
british prosecutor at the icc there's a
british judge joe corner they're
independent but it is part of what we do
to support those institutions and hold
putin to account just to be clear um
someone can be prosecuted in absentia
they don't have to be there at the icc
and um
it doesn't actually matter that you
might say
a commander might say i was only
following orders just to be absolutely
clear anybody who
takes steps that will be defined as a
war crime
can be and will be prosecuted if you
have your way at the icc
whether they turn up they don't turn up
whether they are the putin himself or
their captain on the ground of course
the the the the icc is independent we
need to respect the prosecutorial
judicial independence so these are
decisions for them to make what i'm
saying is it is absolutely right that
there is rigorous full accountability
for anything that happens and the fact
that the icc is looking at this is
something that we don't just support as
a
if you like political uh uh measure
because we're a state party to the icc
but also we will do what it takes with
nuts and bolts cooperation to try and
help them and
and the point i guess at this point in
time while the conflict is raging is to
preserve as much evidence as we can and
they need to know this is your point
well my point the here and now in all of
this is i want and we want and the icc
is making clear that for all of those
commanders on the ground right through
to the people around putin in the
kremlin what they do now whether they
give or whether they follow illegal
orders to commit war crimes they will be
held to account for it and they need to
know that and will it affect morale it
often does in these types of situation
you um and i've spoken before about your
own family's flight from the nuts
invasion of czechoslovakia
more than a million people are fleeing
ukraine the u.n says maybe a million and
a half of cross borders what are we
doing to help people get out to
neighbouring states
well we've as i said we've provided uh
over 200 million pounds in uh
humanitarian assistance we'll work with
the international agencies obviously the
u.n and those european countries that
are closest to ukraine it always happens
that people want to go if they have to
leave their home country and that is
hugely traumatic they'll want to go or
they tend to want to go to places which
are as close as possible because they'll
want to go back as soon as conditions on
the ground help we've also made it clear
both in relation to dependence of
brits here who ukrainian or ukrainians
living here that we will
provide the visa flexibility so we
estimate up to 200 000 could come here
and on top of that there is a
humanitarian protection uh
mechanism that the home secretary has
set up to allow the charitable business
or individual sponsorship of those to
come here from ukraine i want to come to
um
the
the visa
regime in a moment but just sticking
with
what is happening on the borders there
um
we've seen in recent times the flow of
civilians from
uh conflicts being used essentially
weaponized to destabilize other states
belarus did that yeah that and so on
are you concerned that
putin will use this flow to destabilize
poland moldova romania
or frankly as human shields for his own
troops i think anything is possible you
look at what putin has done in the past
in all the wars he's been involved in
you look at the tactics in syria i don't
think that there is any tactic he
wouldn't resort to but i would say this
i think nato and central and eastern
european countries uh are absolutely
resolute and we will support them to the
hilt in not allowing that to be the case
i think what putin's the impact putin
will have on nato on the resilience and
the the resolve of central and eastern
european countries will be the opposite
of what he wishes i think it will only
steal their nerve and we will support
them all the way
all right let's talk about some if i can
put its way more difficult questions
president zielinski has called for a
no-fly zone to be established
by nato nato and in particularly our
government you have responded by saying
that such a step would be
provoking a europe-wide conflict
surely the humanitarian crisis
uh playing out before our eyes
is going to change the calculus over
that
well i think the humanitarian situation
is something we're going to constantly
need to innovate and evolve in our
response to and i'll ultimately try and
stem and prevent but the reality is it's
not just the uk it's all of the nato
allies the u.s has been the same
european partners have been the same
we're not going to either get ourselves
into a direct military conflict with
putin either because that would be a
massive escalation but also that feeds
putin's narrative putin wants to say
that he's actually in a struggle with
the west he's not this is an illegal
invasion of a neighbor whose
self-determination democratic and
territorial integrity needs to be
protected we do not want to feed putin's
narrative yeah but you've just spent
quite a lot of time telling me uh how
much money how much effort we're putting
in to protecting people the truth of the
matter is
we already know that he doesn't
uh he's not that bothered
about damage to done to civilians
and that the humanitarian corridors
could be uh vulnerable the american
diplomat kurt volker from whom we'll be
hearing later in this program um
said to me this week that when the
bodies start piling up in the tens of
thousands the position on the no-fly
zone will change
why not do it now and save those tens of
thousands of lives if we really really
want to protect those people the no-fly
zone even if it's limited to kiev and
the corridors of safety surely it's time
to start that now look i understand the
argument and there's head and heart in
all of this but the reality is
we don't think and our allies don't
think we ought to be sucked into a
direct uh military conflict with
vladimir putin
and that's the position that we've taken
of course it was different if he was
attacking
a nato ally the the position around nato
is very clear um but we will do
everything short of that to support the
ukrainians
and i understand the debate around it
well you say everything short of that
but you know how that will be heard in
ukraine we are prepared to do
anything
up to the point where it will make a
difference well no i don't think that's
true first of all i think the efficacy
of no-fly zones if you look at history
you can think of the iraq example um
they're very difficult they're very
challenging and and secondly if you look
at the impact of our sanctions and the
uk has been at the vanguard of the
international response i think the fact
that putin and this russian central bank
have doubled interest rates to 20
we think of what the cost of living
challenges we're facing here i do think
that that not only puts a squeeze on the
putin war machine but also it shows the
ordinary russian people that this idea
that this is in their interest is for
the birds so at every level i think the
sanctions uh will have an impact but
they won't do so overnight indeed that's
what that's like that that is the point
the problem is
uh for the people of ukraine
overnight is what matters now is what
matters and uh
this geopolitic geopolitics of it and so
on
frankly they may appreciate but it
doesn't save them let's just deal with
point you made by the way two hundred
thousand people you think may come to
the united kingdom now
last week your colleague lis trust said
to me that uh
at the same time on sunday
us uk couldn't commit to admitting any
ukrainians with family here uh by that
evening pretty patel had eased the rules
a bit and that was widely criticized and
friday night you fell into line with the
rest of the eu and admitted uh agreed to
admit people with family here the point
i'm making is why not just take the next
step now rather than having to be
dragged over days to get to do the right
thing
in fairness trev i think if you look uh
the hong kong british national overseas
citizens if you look at operation
pitting and what we did for those
afghans fleeing and our history as a
country i think we've always stepped up
and we have here but you're right to say
that we looked and uh adjusted the uh
family dependence
that was that was a 180 degree turn your
colleague sat there and said no we can't
do that by friday night you were doing
it and absolutely we responded very
swiftly um and and i think that's the
right thing to do and for all the
reasons that you've given and uh and
i've always felt that we should be
open-hearted by the way um you know you
on that
if we started abrogating security checks
on those coming from a war zone i think
first of all would be the wrong thing to
do we've got to look at our security
secondly i think you'll see public
support which has been incredible very
moving and overwhelming i think you
would start to see that phrase in the
same way as let's be honest if we were
engaged in a military direct conflict
with vladimir putin i think the
consensus about what we're doing would
also fray um so just to be clear about
this uh you've got to think these things
through and we've got to be measured as
well as resolute all right look but
isn't the point here
that what seems to happen is not so much
that you're reacting to events but
you're being dragged to events and that
actually what you're really doing is
following
rather than leading on sanctions on the
refugees you've issued stirring press
releases then change the position uh
don't you
is it
what we're seeing here a government
which doesn't want to take the political
risks that are actually involved in
truly confronting putin well i i just
don't think that's true on the facts if
i may say so trevor let me give you the
example of sanctions we were out ahead
and if you take russian banks we have
sanctioned more russian banks in the eu
including spurbank the biggest russian
bank if you take russian companies three
million are subject to restrictions
which means they can't raise finance or
be listed in the uk that was well ahead
of anything the eu has done uh it's true
that the sanctions approach of the u.s
and the eu and the uk they're not
identical but but but i'm afraid i do
not accept your opposition i've been at
the vanguard and actually if you talk to
ordinary ukrainians indeed the ukrainian
ambassador he has paid tribute and they
pay tribute to the resolve and the
solidarity we've shown all right let's
let's take a a very practical exam three
weeks ago uh liz trust told me that
putin's friends and associates this is
her word would have no place to hide
take a look at a picture i'm going to
show you this is a gentleman called
general sergey shoigu he is the russian
defense minister
he should turn up here here he is
there is uh mr putin's closest associate
running the uh he's running the campaign
he met our own defense minister three
weeks ago on february 23rd day before
the invasion
sanctioned by the eu two days later
sanctioned by the usa
11 days after the russians invaded he is
still not sanctioned by us why not look
i'm always very careful not to talk
about individuals because in relation to
criminal prosecutions or sanctions but
let me answer the question but let me
answer the question squarely but it's
not right actually to for me to
pre-judge all uh any legal action we
take it's very serious it needs to be
done on the evidence and on the legal
days yeah but these things you need to
have evidence that he has got assets
here so the eu and the
and the usa are basically breaching like
proper proper legal well i don't know
him relationships
but first of all he's got to have
evidence of the legal criteria he's also
got to have assets uh if you're talking
about immediate action against assets in
the uk so we do have to we don't have
the rule of law in this country we do do
these things uh carefully but and as a
result of that by the way we have far
more impact when i introduced the sergei
magnitsky sanctions for human rights
abuses but also for corruption based on
the biggest tax fraud in russian history
we we had all of these arguments about
whether we moved more quickly which we
did in many cases also but the reality
is we avoided successful legal challenge
against those sanctions nothing would be
a greater pr coup for putin than if we
put sanctions on someone and then we
found they were successfully appealed so
we do act swiftly okay and that is
important we also need to need to make
sure we can do so sustainably because
that's where the credibility comes well
will you then stop your colleague the
prime minister going about saying that
we've sanctioned 100 people we've it's
over 100
entities and i think if you take since
2014 250 individuals have been
sanctioned
but
this person who has been sanctioned by
pretty much everybody else isn't
sanctioned by us you'll always be able
to do this um uh trevor you're about to
point to that one or other if you take
the picture overall and look not just at
individuals but the corporate uh
uh vehicles that they uh have assets uh
through banks companies as well as
individuals i i uh we yield to no one in
our record they're not just moving
swiftly but also robustly and again
those figures on banks and companies
three million russian companies and
often you find the associates or the
individuals are operating through those
businesses or banks account now list on
the uk stock market cannot now raise
money uh loans in the uk
all right well let's talk about uh how
far we're prepared to go the
wars already caused a huge spike in
energy costs
when you're going to tell the british
people
that
they are going to have to pay
a price here
and by the way might it not be the
moment for you to think again about that
national insurance tax rise of one and a
quarter per cent given the pain that
we're going to have to face well look
first of all uh in terms of the uh
the funding of social care i think we
should be dealing with the social care
problem it's been ducked uh by
successive governments i'm proud that
this government is going to deal with
the social care challenge that so many
people face on energy prices we've been
very clear if you have a global crisis a
conflict involving
russia or any other oil gas producer
it's going to have an impact on global
prices in fact we get just four percent
of our gas from
russia so we are uh
we are much less reliant than others but
what we're going to do in terms of
supply is keep expanding the renewables
we're going to invest more um in nuclear
particularly those small nuclear
reactors and we're also going to make
sure we can rely for resilience on the
north side but the price the price of
energy is going to go up
we know that so let me tell you the only
way you're going to be able to protect
people is by expanding supply so
are you going to tell people that
they're going to pay a thousand and plus
more or by the way are you going to
think about returning to coal or
fracking no we're not going to do
something we're not going to return to
coal but i've given you the three areas
and also oil production where we'll have
more resilience renewables and nuclear
where we do need to increase supply and
that is already part of our strategy in
terms of protecting consumers i mean
just to be clear the chancellor and the
prime minister have put 20 billion
pounds into the cost of living challenge
that we face right now to protect
consumers nine billion of that is to
support with energy bills uh so from the
uh winter fuel payments through to the
the discounts and the rebates on council
tax and energy bills we're already
providing this support to make sure we
can see ourselves through what we hope
will be a temporary crisis
all right
let's talk very briefly now about the
potential end game
mr putin has said overnight that
sanctions
are an act of war
do you fear that
a cornered isolated kremlin with its
troops bogged down in a
conflict that uh mr putin didn't
anticipate
could actually reach for the nuclear
button
now i think the the debate and the
rhetoric around that is just that um but
what it does show you i mean first of
all just to be clear sanctions are not
uh an act of war international law was
very clear about that our sanctions are
entirely both legally justified but also
proportionate to what we're trying to
deal with but what it does show you is
that this has not been the cakewalk
putin expected and it's not just us
hearing that message it's russian people
and those russian conscripts who were
told they were peacekeepers in ukraine
who were finding fearsome resistance
from the ukrainians but but this was not
what what uh their their
commander-in-chief had promised them but
i should say to you that he has said i
think it's come out this morning by the
russian news agency that ukraine is
developing a dirty nuclear bomb no
evidence for that whatever
but could that be preparation on his
part for an escalation to the use of
what
i think
ludicrously but anyway i called
battlefield nuclear weapons i think it's
rhetoric and brinkmanship and
uh putin's at various times i mean he's
got a track record as long as anyone's
arm
of misinformation and propaganda we saw
that through the pandemic and this is a
distraction from what the real issues
are at hand which is that uh it's an
inva illegal invasion uh and it is not
going according to plan you're
absolutely right though trevor to say uh
that makes him even more unpredictable
and uh that's why working in the un
working with our nato allies working
with our international partners around
the world i mean china has got uh a job
here they've got to step up as well this
is a permanent member of the security
council um india as well so we need to
expand the diplomatic pressure um but
but let's not get distracted by the the
propaganda of putin deputy prime
minister thank you so much
the shadow defense secretary john healey
joins me now
good morning uh mr healy
um
does dominic rob's assessment of the
military situation on on the ground uh
seem reasonable given what you know
yes
the russians may have
seriously miscalculated the strength of
the
ukrainian military more importantly
they've putin has miscalculated on the
strength of
ukrainian national identity and their
determination to resist in the face of
this
invasion and in the face of putin coming
in and killing people
bombing bombing their cities in a
sovereign state
that russia itself promised under
international law to respect
where do you stand on the ukrainian
appeal for a no-fly zone whether over
the whole of ukraine or as has been
suggested by some people
a limited zone of kiev and the
humanitarian corridors
yes nato has ruled this out and the most
essential thing is that the
western alliance remains together
it's done so because
establishing a
no-fly zone will mean shooting russian
fighters out of the
sky
it will do
too little to protect the ukrainians
from the
artillery and missile fire now being
directed into civilian neighborhoods
and
the big risk is that it gives
putin the grounds to rapidly escalate
this conflict and of course it gives him
the get out of jail free card to explain
to his own people
why his military campaign and his
invasion in ukraine is not going well
i'm going to be talking to a
person
on the ground
in ukraine
tell me how i explained to her
why we are not responding because i hear
what you've just said
but from her point of view and i imagine
from president zlensky's point of view
and most of his people
this feels like the west saying
we are happy to support you
except in order to do the thing that
will really protect you
this is genuinely
deeply deeply disturbing very difficult
and the hard fact is that
well the hard fact is ukraine is
not a member of nato so the collective
security commitments that we have don't
apply but britain has led the way
rightly with labour's full support in
providing the military assistance for
ukrainians to defend themselves when i
was in ukraine in january the ukrainians
were very clear they knew it was their
fight and they were determined to resist
russia in a way that putin has
miscalculated so the best
thing that britain and
western countries can do at the moment
is to step up the military assistance as
we have been doing to help the
ukrainians defend themselves
support
so forgive me do you agree with dominic
rob's skepticism that a cornered kremlin
could step up uh its use of greater and
more unconventional firepower chemical
biological weapons even nuclear weapons
before i answer that i just wanted to
finish what i was saying before because
the other thing that we must do
in maintaining the international
condemnation of russia is also to press
for an immediate
ceasefire and then the withdrawal
of russian troops but importantly and
this is a job for the united nations to
make sure that we have humanitarian
corridors maintained into these cities
under russian attack in terms of putin
putin we have seen from his record in
chechnya
where he
bombed the capital garage knee almost to
the ground and then sent in hit squads
to assassinate individuals that
continued to resist we've seen in syria
we've seen attacks on our own british
soil as well as him seizing the nuclear
power plant in
ukraine how
dangerous this man is and
at the heart of this war
is the danger of escalation
and the discipline and unity from nato
and from the west
in putting in tough sanctions
and making sure that we reinforce our
nato eastern flank
but saying to putin everything now
depends on you
being willing to negotiate and to start
to de-escalate it's putin that's
escalating and it's putin that must
de-escalate if we're going to find a way
through
this
war
that isn't quite an answer to if i may
say it's a question i asked dominic robb
said he thought that all of the
uh talk about a nuclear alert and so on
was just rhetoric he would not go there
do you agree
well at times of
extreme crisis like this
what
uh senior political figures say matters
putin has been
used to ramping up rhetoric
he's also been willing to step up
very aggressive uh
military action as we've seen in other
countries
it should
redouble our determination to support
the ukrainian resistance but also to try
and find a negotiated solution as we
remain united as a western alliance
in saying to russia you may be making
short-term military gains in ukraine but
you will fail in the longer run
you've criticized the government for
being slow on sanctions i talked to
mr
rob about that a moment ago um
what would labour do about general shuy
gu or indeed about mr abramovic
neither of whom are on as far as we know
on the uk sanctions list
yeah we've been arguing for some time
for nearly six years since
the scale of the dirty money that helped
keep putin in power washing through
london that action's been required and
for six years we've been arguing for the
economic crime bill that the house of
commons only tomorrow will get to debate
for the first time so the
sanctions that the government has been
willing to put in place the legislation
it's had in order to do so
has been faulty and flawed for too long
and so
that's why kia stammer this morning is
saying to the government look
finally this economic crime bill is
important it will give us some of the
legislative and economic weapons we
don't yet have
but it needs toughening up and if the
government will work with labor to do
that during the passage of this
legislation rapidly through the house of
commons and lords we will give them full
cooperation in doing so
this um invasion has
forced i think many people to rethink
stances that they've had about things
for a long time sweden
now plans to spend more on defense uh so
does germany um will labor support a
significant increase in the uk's
military spending
well labour backed the big increase in
capital spending the prime minister
announced in late 2020
i would expect to see a big boost to
defence in the budget in two weeks time
the government must
must respond
to increased threats
and increased threats to our security in
europe just as labour did when we were
in government after the 9 11 attacks on
the twin towers
john healey thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning
thank you
ukrainians are waking up to day 11 of
war
british military intelligence has said
that both the scale and the strength of
the ukrainian resistance have continued
to frustrate the russian invasion aid
agencies estimate the number of
ukrainian refugees could reach a million
and a half this weekend
ukrainian citizen anastasia krishka
joins us now from near kiev good morning
anastasia
um morning hi
thank you for having me
thank you for joining us tell us well
first of all tell us how you personally
are and um
what
is the situation on the ground where you
are
um
well now it's relatively safe where i am
um the first two days i've actually
spent in the kiev
city center with my
boyfriend and then we had a chance to
kind of
escape to
the kiev area nearby
we still hear a lot of
explosions and shootings and everything
so
even though it is safe-ish
you come really safe be safe
right now anywhere in ukraine
so but i am
like in the house we have food we have
electricity and light and everything so
i am
lucky if you may say compared to other
people
who are in much much worse situations
than we are
where you are are you able to move
around at all or are you confined to
the the dwelling we we don't leave the
house um i haven't left the house in uh
over 10 days the only uh outside that i
go is like the little outside garden
that we have here on the
um actual like house
garden
um
where we can walk our dog and that's it
i haven't gone outside
my boyfriend did he go sometimes to get
some food and even though that's still a
challenge because all the nearby shops
they don't have
anything
pretty much you have to get there like
really early to get like some milk and
maybe
one loaf of bread and that's pretty much
it
what is the most difficult part of uh
what you're having to deal with on a
day-to-day basis
the uh
fear of not knowing
of
like whether you're gonna
make it
if you're gonna make it or not um
till the morning basically because you
don't know where they will
shoot next or where they will come next
and um
that's
definitely the most terrifying part but
finally i got a chance to get my parents
here because they were also in the kiev
city center and they didn't want to
leave and i was begging them because
we're actually in the house with my
boyfriend's parents
and i had a chance to get my parents
here uh two days ago and i'm kind of
like more at peace but still it's
terrifying
to
be here
i i can tell how difficult it is um
you are
in contact on social media i think with
a lot of uh other people particularly
young ukrainians what are you hearing
from them
um well i have a lot of ukrainian
friends and
friends all over the world because i
actually went
to school in uni in england so i have
people all over the world
um and ukrainians as well and what i see
on social media is
remark remarkable sorry
um because everyone is trying to help
everyone each other and
everyone who even has like 100 followers
they're trying to spread the word as
much as possible
and uh
help um
us because i have a lot of ukrainian
friends who are now not in ukraine and
they're doing so much for us
um
and yeah the community that we have here
is
truly inspiring
and we've always been
very very
uh loyal to our country and very loving
of our country very proud to be
ukrainians
um
but at this point it just got to the to
next level absolute crazy level where
people who never spoke they don't know
each other they're from different ends
of ukraine and ukraine is big
they are
willing to put their life down to help
someone else and we have so many
volunteers
tragically who
have been
killed
on the way to help others
yeah what would you
you have the chance to speak to
people all over the world
what would you like the rest of the
world to be doing
um well i would like to
say thank you to everyone who is helping
that's really really
um we're very grateful
but um what i want to really say is that
we're not as far as you think what's
happening here is not as far from you as
you might think
um
[Music]
what's happening here
can tragically unfortunately happen to
anyone at this point because
the uh
dictator the uh our neighbor the mr
putin he
he's a madman and no one knows what's in
his mind he's been
bombing our nuclear power plant power
plant you know um
the biggest one in europe
the biggest
and everyone knows chernobyl and
if this tragedy happens that's six times
bigger
and
no one's gonna be able to hide or be
you know that's
that's the way that's in ukraine that's
far
um
so i just want to say that
we're not far what's happening here is
not far
and um
all the like the closing of the sky
for us
at some point it could be too late
at some point i just don't understand
how many innocent lives have to be taken
the kids and everyone
for
other people to finally understand that
it has to be done
there is no point where you can be like
okay yeah now we can finally do it it
has to be done
it has to be done
anastasia
thank you very much indeed and uh from
us in london
sochastia
thank you
thank you
so
could the uk be doing more to help the
ukraine defend itself and if so what
could that mean for britain's own
security
air marshal philip osborne is a former
chief of defense intelligence and
director at universal defence and
security solutions he's here with me now
good morning marshall good morning um
mr zielanski and his people um
just heard there
want the introduction of a no-fly zone
and that's been
resisted and we understand the formal
reasons but
do you think that's
going to be true forever
i guess it depends
where the west wants to end up excuse me
um militarily you can put in place in
the fly zone
it's complex
it's
dangerous uh has a risk associated with
it militarily
um but the issue i think is less than
military reasons and much more
um the consequences
um
a while ago i've been involved in
policing no-fly zones and and the
critical issue is you have to enforce
them what that means is not just
threatening and sometimes shooting down
opposition aircraft uh it means
targeting air defense systems that are
trying to stop you operating in the
no-fly zone
in this context it would mean we'd have
to be willing to attack russian perhaps
belarusian forces not just in ukraine
but perhaps in belarus and perhaps in
russia
so
that that risk of escalation
significant escalation and the quite
um clear path to further conflict is
something that the west has got to be
comfortable with has got to be ready for
um if it implements a no-fly zone
do you think that the intelligence
assessment that the politicians will be
getting now would be saying
you could do that
but in truth rather than
uh
creating a situation in which the
russians and belarusians can back off
it would be on balance
uh
a provocation to for them to step up uh
their firepower
i think we have to perhaps take a step
back here
um
putin's in a hole he's in a corner um
he's
he's personalized the conflict in
ukraine
and therefore that brings with it all
kinds of risks his options are
not nearly as clear as they were at the
start of this conflict you know only 11
days ago
but also at home he really needs to
maintain a narrative maintain a
um a rationale
which is where he's going at the moment
which is this is counternato
this is this is to stop nato
expansionism this is all about the
security of russia
um
part of the implementation of the no-fly
zone gives him that opportunity to
underline that narrative at home to make
this about
nato and russia not about
his miscalculation in ukraine
so i think
it is the
the options it gives him
to
step up into what he wants to be saying
um that is a real risk that the
the western governments will be thinking
about and being being advised on
okay well let's suppose that doesn't
happen
things
proceed pretty much as they are now
do you think he's told um president
macron in a phone call last week
that he wants to control the whole of
ukraine um
how realistic is that given the size of
that territory four times the size of
england i think um i i think there's two
things there there's the size of the
territory we'll come back to that but
there's 40 million people that don't
want him there and they're showing every
day with
remarkable resistance bravery
um
stoicism
that
he just can't hold that country i think
any nation
who thinks it's going to hold a country
of 40 million plus people who just don't
want you there regardless of the size as
killing themselves
so he may be saying that
[Music]
taking over ukraine removing it as a
supposed threat to to russia is his end
state i just can't see him being advised
even by those yes menders around him um
that that's possible
and therefore
he must be looking for
some kind of way out perhaps partition
um which allows him to shift the
narrative to say hey look you know i've
achieved what i wanted to achieve
but i think we come back to he's in a
corner this is not where he planned to
be he planned to have a puppet regime in
place on day two i mean one of the other
reasons that perhaps things haven't
panned out in a way that um he might
have expected
is that um
as many analysts have said they're
rather surprised at what seems to be the
poor performance of russian forces um
has he got a white elephant on his hands
he spent a lot of money
um bringing those armed forces up to
scratch but they don't seem to be doing
what he wants
um at the heart of military power is is
people
it's have you got the right people with
the right morale the right training
and
the right skills to do the type of
things he's trying to do so yes you're
right there's a lot of expensive
equipment and a lot of it is stuck in
muddy ditches uh in ukraine at the
moment now if we take a step back again
i think what we're seeing is a hugely
overconfident
russian military
engaging with the reality of a really
high-end well-equipped highly motivated
opponent
so so i think we've seen an error of
overconfidence as far as they're
concerned and they have underestimated
the ukrainians
that's led to
tactical and operational level failures
in terms of logistics
in terms of command and control
but
but what i think is also underlined is
that russia is just not used to doing
this type of stuff
big coordinated air land maritime
operations on many axes
are really difficult and nations like
the uk the us and others
train really hard to make
to ensure you've got that capability
russia's not been doing that
is uh
one consequence of
him being as you put it in a hole
that he simply just has to get as it
were a bigger cudgel i.e
uh
more firepower shelling of civilian
targets for example
um we're already there
i mean what we're seeing is
is the chechnya is the syria playbook um
he was trying to be fast he was trying
to be
manipulative of public opinion you know
puppet regime perhaps in two or three
days that's clearly not worked um his
forces are proving that they're not
nearly as agile as they thought they
were going to be
and therefore what we're seeing
um
tragically is russia doing what russia
normally does which is when it's in a
whole applies violence extreme violence
um
to break civilian morale i think
personally in the ukrainians they pick
the wrong opponent and when we say
extreme violence how extreme you know
what i'm really asking here
what is he prepared to use
um
in terms of in ukraine he'll be prepared
to use cluster weapons he's already seen
those
he'll be prepared to use the barbaric
weapons we've seen those deployed
to go further than that again is to risk
a
highly significant escalation
which
even those deluded individuals around
putin um i think would be advising him
against um this is a this is a
multi-level conflict
and
actions at the tactical and operational
level do have strategic impact it's a
dangerous time and he'll recognize it's
a dangerous time
so i would assess at this stage
weapons beyond those conventional
weapons of mass destruction that i've
just mentioned
i can't see those being used within
ukraine in a tactical context
hey marshall phil osborne thank you so
much thank you
president zelinski has repeated call for
an immediate no-fly zone to protect
civilians from aerial attack but his
police have so far fallen on deaf ears
so can and should nato do more to save
lives and deter vladimir putin
earlier i spoke to kurt volker a former
u.s ambassador to nato and special
representative
for ukraine negotiations in the trump
administration
when we spoke in january you said that
mr putin had put all the forces in place
for
a large invasion i'm quoting you there
and it was more likely than not that he
would use them
could we have done more to deter him
yes um it's unfortunate but true you
know we could see it we could see the
build-up of forces we heard his rhetoric
we knew he had made demands that could
not be met
so it was just becoming increasingly
clear
that he would invade
i wasn't sure whether it would be
trying to take over the whole country
and depose the government or just take
parts of eastern ukraine and sadly is
what he is very clear about now is he
wants to kill zolinski decapitate the
government and control the entire
country
and you think that he uh
really
is completely bent on his war aim now
come what may irrespective of casualties
and
international condemnation and so on
yes in fact i think he has given himself
no way out
uh he launched this military operation
on the thought that it might last two or
three days it would be fairly easy they
would take over ukraine obviously not
true russian forces are bogged down in
many places they've suffered a lot of
casualties a lot of equipment losses and
now these sanctions have kicked in that
are truly significant against the
russian economy
so
he has to win to save face to save
himself to remain in power because if he
fails in ukraine and the economy is
tanking i would not be surprised to see
people in russia start to question his
leadership
do you think uh this is what might be
called the cornered rat problem
that actually
if you corner
the rat he or she will just become more
savage
and do things that
in other circumstances will be
unimaginable
yes that's true and we're seeing it
already so russian you know multiple
rocket launchers are firing at civilian
populations and apartment buildings and
cities in kharkiv mariopol and garcon in
kiev and
missile strikes on civilian targets in
cities
aircraft they haven't gained air
superiority yet
but they are trying to and they want to
completely suppress the population by
breaking its will and defeating the
military on the battlefield
mr biden uh
in his state of the union address this
week i i think devoted
not much more than about 10 minutes to
ukraine which
uh seems like a surprise given the
circumstances do you think that was an
indication that in reality the united
states
now thinks that there's relatively
little it can do to change
the course of mr putin's actions
well first off i do want to give
president buying credit on two fronts
one of them uh he did speak extensively
about ukraine 10 minutes in the state of
the union is significant and it's the
first topic he brought up so he he gave
it some priority and secondly his
rhetoric
about defending democracy and standing
up to putin's aggression
i thought that rhetoric was great the
problem is that the actions have not
matched that rhetoric
and we have been intimidated by russia i
would say uh fearing that he might reach
for a nuclear weapon fearing a direct
conflict with russian forces that could
escalate and so rather than deterring
russia he is deterring us
well you've said out uh this week in in
an article a number of things that you
think
that the west that nato could be doing
and in particular um you've
taken note of what the ukrainians
themselves have been saying that they
want nato to establish a no-fly zone
you've called for that in a more limited
fashion i think than president
zielenski's talked about to cover kiev
and humanitarian routes out of ukraine
um how would that work
well uh first off uh we've done this in
the past we we've executed no-fly zones
we've done it over the kurdish areas in
iraq for example when sodom hussein was
attacking them
so we know how to do this we there is a
protocol for this secondly we make very
clear this is for humanitarian purposes
only we are there to prevent attacks on
the civilian population from the air
and
we do this over kiev and western ukraine
so it's limited geographically we are
not coming close to russian borders
and we make very clear the rules of
engagement we will not be striking any
ground targets any russian forces unless
fired upon
and we will not be striking any russian
aircraft or helicopters provided they
remain outside the zone
and if they enter the zone then there's
a protocol of escalating uh tactics to
to escort them out
but if they refuse then there would be
the prospect of firing on them but many
ways to avoid that and i think the
russians will understand this as well
they might test us but then i think they
don't want to draw us into a larger
conflict either
well let me
push back a little bit on that do you
really think
that mr putin
is going to play by rules that nato has
set out he hasn't been interested in
nato what nato has had to say about
anything thus far
yeah i think uh it's forced that he
respects its force that he listens to uh
not um
the rules that are stated so if he sees
that we are doing it and we are prepared
to follow through i think he will adjust
but
of course what people
worry about is that
his reaction might not be
the reasonable one that that you've just
set out but simply to say this is an act
of war we are now at war and you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to win
this war with every force at my disposal
and we know what that means including
chemical biological and nuclear yeah
which which would be horrific and if
that is the kind of dictator and
aggressor that we are dealing with in
europe today then we also know he won't
stop at ukraine um he wants to subdue
ukraine he'll move on to moldova i think
that was already in the plans uh he'll
look at georgia and he may even be
looking at the baltic states which we
have an obligation to defend so i think
it is prudent to take steps now to
assist the ukrainians as they have an
organized government and military and
are fighting back rather than waiting
until it is disorganized in ukraine and
putin is in a dominant position and
moving on to other pieces of the empire
let me ask you
i guess a question that i put you in our
previous interview
if
we don't for example introduce a no-fly
zone
is it your view that ultimately the
ukrainians are going to have to submit
to russian control
no
i think the ukrainians are going to
continue fighting
and even if uh the russians managed to
kill zielinski
and even if they managed to break the
military organization
then the ukrainians will be fighting
from the cities and the woods uh in an
internal insurgency against a russian
occupying force this is going to go on
uh regardless
so this is potentially what our own
foreign secretary
called before the invasion the potential
for a quagmire for the russians um i
think she was uh calling to bind uh
afghanistan
maybe the first chechen war
yeah the difference between a quagmire
as we would understand it
and what would be happening in ukraine
under those circumstances is the
russians are absolutely brutal they
won't play by any rules of nicety they
will kill civilians indiscriminately
they will be incredibly brutal and that
is again another reason we should be
looking at ways to stop this before it
happens
um let me just ask you lastly one thing
which as a former official
you've served under a number of
presidents
including president trump
it's been said to me actually on
television this week
that were president trump in the white
house mr putin would never have dared
to be so
audacious so brutal
so uh aggressive
do you agree with that
it's hard to know
it's hard to know
the um i think there is an element to
which president trump was highly
unpredictable
and i think putin was
not sure what trump would do
i also think that he
believed that trump was comfortable
using force
look at the way we took out the head of
the iranian revolutionary guard
uh or
you know pushed back um
in syria and against isis you know there
was a there was a bit of aggressiveness
in the approach
which i think putin saw and that also
increased uncertainty but that being
said
uh putin is bent on this mission to
rebuild the russian empire
on the ashes of the former soviet union
he wants to regather the territories
he's been explicit about it and so
i think his being driven
to do this would be the case whether it
was president trump or president biden
countries in the west and elsewhere have
so far used economic sanctions as the
main weapon to punish russia for its
actions in ukraine
said to be the strongest ever imposed
against moscow remains to be seen
whether they will be enough to force
vladimir putin to think again tom
keating is a financial security expert
at the royal united services institute
and he joins me now good morning mr
keating
good morning um
boyce johnson insisted at prime
minister's questions on wednesday that
britain is uh quote leading the way when
it comes to sanctions on russia is that
claim justified
well the uk should be leading the way we
have a global financial centre full of
russian banks full of russian money full
of russian investment and therefore we
absolutely have to lead the way and when
you look at the numbers the government
would argue yes however the government
has put out there that targeting
oligarchs is a measure and on that
measure the uk is not leading the way
when you say uh well who else is is uh
ahead of us as it were
well the the european union and the u.s
have moved faster on individuals i think
the government here has recognized that
they have tied themselves up in knots
with their sanctions law but it is
clearly the case that when it comes to
freezing central bank assets and other
parts of financial infrastructure the uk
is definitely taking a lead
do you think that
the
situation that you've described that
at some level we're lagging behind
others will have been an encouragement
to uh oligarch to basically start moving
their their wealth i mean the the sort
of marquee example is uh what mr
abramovic has been doing at chelsea
any any oligarch worth their billions of
dollars uh i'm afraid we'll have
contingency plans in place uh so we've
seen yachts moving around the world
we've seen private jets moving around
the world of course not all assets can
be moved quickly you can't sell a 45
million pound house in london overnight
but we can certainly expect these
individuals to put up a tremendous fight
uh if they are uh sanctioned in the uk
eventually
do you think that the focus that has
been on individual big names and i've
mentioned one i spoke to
um
uh mr robert about others and
has been helpful
i i don't think so i can see how it's
appealing uh to say oligarchs can't hide
their money here um and indeed the uk
has had a long decades-long problem with
dirty russian money uh in london and
elsewhere in the country so this is not
to say we should be ignoring this
problem we've ignored it for too long
and uh we have seen the results of
ignoring that but fundamentally what we
need to be doing is crushing the russian
economy going after oligarchs helps
because these are the people who if
anyone can whisper in putin's ear
it is them but in reality i think making
oligarchs the marquee the the measure by
which you're going to
judge the progress you're making i think
has been unhelpful for the government uh
you've in fact described the current
financial sanctions as
toothless um
is that a bit harsh
that was my response initially i think
the west was weak initially in its in
its first response the whole point of
sanctions is to deter putin and at the
first opportunity to show that we have a
strong and we meant business uh we
fluffed it since then i must say the
sanctions particularly on financial
infrastructure on the central bank uh
have been very strong so i wouldn't say
they were toothless however there is an
elephant in the room here which is
sanctions on energy on gas and on oil
major major contributors to the russian
economy and of course so far
those remain untouched
what would we do or what should we do
from your point of view on those sectors
i think there are two things obviously
uh the eu in particular has an addiction
to russian gas that is not something
that's going to change overnight on oil
if we remember back to the iran era on
oil basically countries were told you
don't have to cut off your purchase of
iranian oil overnight but you need to
demonstrate month on month that you are
reducing uh your imports so i think that
needs to be a near-term and urgent
mission which the uk should be leading
on that as well
uh in fact i if i seem to recall that
the obama administration had a sort of
uh staggered program of sanctions uh
over time uh which essentially i suppose
was meant to put the squeeze is that the
sort of thing you have in mind
yeah that's exactly the sort of thing
i i have in i have in mind i mean energy
if we don't sanction energy then we are
not sanctioning the russian economy to
the extent that the foreign secretary
and others have called for uh the most
massive consequences will be if we
indeed go now after energy
um of course you you
said the beginning of this conversation
that uh london was in a special place
because there's so much money of
different kinds flowing through here and
there's a lot of conversation about
dirty money but let me ask you
practically do you think we can actually
get at this so-called dirty money
because some of it doesn't come
directly from russia
the people whose names are mentioned
uh aren't on the deeds for the
properties and uh they're owned by
companies in jurisdictions like the
caymans or
cyprus or somewhere else
do you think actually we're really going
to be able to get at this money
it's really important not to mistake
taking sanctions action against russia
for dealing with the uk's dirty money
problem dealing with the uk's dirty
money problem needs to be done by
building our defenses strengthening our
defenses so this is why this economic
crime bill which is coming forward is so
important that will bring transparency
to foreign ownership of property in the
uk for example sanctions does not deal
with dirty money sanctions freezes the
assets of those who are committing human
rights abuses or destabilizing and
invading ukraine but we have to build
our defenses domestically to stop dirty
money coming into this country we then
need to do our best to try and identify
the dirty money that's here already
that's very challenging but not building
our defenses up is inexcusable
one of the um oligarchs has said
publicly and i think some of them have
been saying privately um
why are you getting after us because we
really have no influence
uh over mr putin and
one has to say that there is some um
you know there's some evidence that
almost nobody has influence over mr
putin and getting after these guys may
make us feel better but may not have any
impact whatsoever on putin
i mean there are two important points on
that firstly the uk sanctions law says
that those who have benefited from or
support the russian government can be
subject to sanction so there is no doubt
that these individuals have benefited
from being close to the russian
government over the year and indeed many
would argue that in some cases they are
guardians of uh putin's wealth you know
they they haven't become wealthy without
his blessing and his blessing comes with
a price tag so i think to say that you
know we we don't have influence that
might be right but to say we haven't
benefited and therefore we're not
somehow connected to this regime it's
just straight wrong
tom keating thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning
thank
you
the uk economy was already under growing
pressure from rising prices and supply
chain issues before the ukraine crisis
but now experts predict things could get
even worse i'm joined by rayne
newton-smith the chief economist at the
confederation of british industry good
morning with newton smith
good morning
let's talk about energy
uh which has come up a number of times
already this morning how serious is the
rise in costs going to be
for business
i i i think it is serious but i think
first and foremost all of our thoughts
at the moment are with the people in
ukraine and i think if you talk to most
businesses at the moment in the uk the
things they are most concerned about is
what is their role and how can they help
with the humanitarian efforts uh to
support people fleeing from ukraine
and what can they do to implement the
economic sanctions that are in place
most effectively so i think that is what
is first and foremost in any businesses
minds
um you're right though as we look at the
fallout for what this means for the uk
economy and for the global economy one
of the biggest impacts that we are
seeing now and we'll see in future
is higher energy prices and higher
inflation and that will put more
pressure uh on ordinary households uh in
the uk but i think we have to caveat
that in that the thing that is foremost
in people's minds uh is this conflict
we're seeing in in ukraine and how we
can help support people there uh and
also citizens here well i want to come
to that in a moment but i i should ask
you really
um
british businesses presumably have uh
quite a lot of employees in ukraine
and also in russia what are your
thoughts about the risks to those
individuals and what are businesses
doing
to protect them
yeah look i think it's it's a really
difficult time for for any business who
has staff uh in in ukraine or in russia
and they are asking themselves some
really difficult questions and i think
first and foremost it's of course
supporting any staff or operations you
have uh in ukraine making sure that they
are state and of course many businesses
here in the uk uh have you british
ukrainian staff uh working for them who
have families uh who are in uh you know
are who are impacted by this dreadful
conflict so our thoughts are definitely
with them
and of course there are businesses as
well
who will have operations in russia who
will have staff employed
in russia and what we've seen is many
businesses have made really difficult
uh decisions to either close their
operations uh in russia but one of the
things that first and foremost is to
make sure
that the staff that they have in russia
are also safe so i don't think there are
any easy decisions for businesses here
but first and foremost they're thinking
about the safety of their staff then how
they can uh implement the economic
sanctions as effectively as possible
uh and how um you know and ultimately
their responsibilities to create jobs
here uh in the uk and to
ensure that they're able to continue to
produce goods and services to their
customers and clients
to return to the
point we were discussing a moment ago on
energy um it is still
i think
the issue of the moment for businesses
and for economic uh
ministers the question of what we do
about the effect of sanctions on the
energy sector uh obviously uh much much
more sensitive i guess in uh on
continental europe but still
a problem for us partly because i think
uh you've said the cbi that any
disruption in the european gas supply
chain with russia
could have
a more severe shock on the whole market
than we currently anticipate could you
explain what you have in mind there and
what impact it would have
on people here
yeah so i think there's a few things to
separate out there first of all
the biggest impact we're seeing on
energy prices and that's of course both
oil but also natural gas
is not actually from direct sanctions at
the moment it's from the conflict uh
already that is happening and um and so
i think it isn't just about the
sanctions it's about the fact that we're
facing a war in europe and that is
having an impact on energy prices
directly um secondly i think what we do
know in the uk in terms of our own
exposure is around five percent of our
natural gas uh imports are from russia
for europe it's much higher it's about
40 percent of all natural gas
uh so that gives you a sense of our sort
of direct exposure
but i think what's hap what we're seeing
happening here in the uk and if we were
seeing this impact before uh the
conflict really escalated is that we are
facing high energy uh prices that has a
big impact on households primarily uh in
april the energy price cap
went up as a result of the fact that
energy prices are much higher globally
and again in october we'll likely see a
further increase in energy prices that
households
are facing and of course that's most
challenging for low-income households
who spend a bigger proportion of their
income
on heating their homes so i think
there's the squeeze on households but
the other issue that we face is of
course for businesses themselves higher
energy prices means higher costs uh for
their operations and i think an example
you can give of that is particularly
like cert in the ceramics industry so if
you're a brick manufacturer energy cost
is a big part of what you are of the
cost that you face and that's suddenly
gone up uh significantly so i think
what's important is that uh the uk
government thinks about the impact on
households and does what they can to
support particularly low-income
households through this transition but
also thinks about some of those
businesses particularly smaller
businesses who face big costs on from
energy and think about how they smooth
the transition to these higher energy
prices and there's something called the
recovery loan scheme which was put in
place uh partly to help businesses
through
covid that could be extended for another
six months to really help some of those
smaller businesses who are suddenly
facing a much much more challenging uh
economic environment here in the uk
uh finally just uh returning to the
specific issue of sanctions um i know
that you have spent a lot of time
studying um china's role in the global
economy
um one thing i think hasn't been talked
about too much yet
is whether china
might play a role in either
reinforcing or being neutral to
or actually undermining sanctions
through its new
economic relationship with russia do you
think that beijing could in fact come to
moscow's rescue if sanctions start to
bite
i mean i think that's really a question
for the chinese government i think
what's most important at the moment is
that for economic sanctions to work
effectively we need international uh
coordination and i think what would be
a you know real shame or a bad outcome
from is that if the uk and other
governments uh retreat from some of that
international cooperation i think what
we saw last year through uh the g7 where
the uk was leading that presidency and
what we've seen as well through the g20
where where countries across emerging
markets come together to work
effectively and we need to see more
international coordination
and we need to work with china
to make these economic sanctions work
effectively
and i think that's what we need to see
is all countries reaching out to other
governments to work effectively
and i think it's important that we don't
retreat from globalization that we don't
retreat
from those conversations and
international diplomacy i think that
would be a real travesty for the uk but
also
for the world economy if we don't engage
in some of these international forums we
don't work with the un and other
countries to implement these sanctions
as effectively
as possible
and continuing to trade within the remit
of these economic sanctions
ray newton-smith cbi thank you so much
indeed
thank you
now despite widespread international
condemnation of the attack on ukraine
one of russia's most important allies
china has been much less critical as
we've just been
hearing nevertheless
many believe putin's actions have left
beijing in an awkward place with a key
strategic partner that has grown closer
to over recent years
earlier i spoke to youn sun a political
analyst and director of the china
program at the stimson center in
washington dc
china's leadership has been very muted
really in its response to the invasion
of ukraine do you think that they
anticipated this in any way
i think they were anticipating russia to
do something at least by the beginning
of february as in the chinese census
that while russia has what they call
legitimate security concerns and during
putin's trip to beijing as in the
chinese speculation is that well there's
probably some
russian actions
to to come in the uh in the in the
months to in the months to come
um but i think the chinese were not
expecting russia to launch a full-scale
invasion
into ukraine the most they saw that
moscow would do
would be a repetition of what they did
in crimea in 2014 so help the two
territories in eastern ukraine to become
independent
uh through a referendum and russian
support so they will basically achieve
russia's goal
of
addressing a security concerns but
without a full scale invasion so the
full school invasion part definitely
came as a shock to the chinese and the
chinese think that it's overdone is
uncalled for
oh right
where do you think it leaves their
relationship with moscow then because
that relationship was being built up and
was looking pretty close
well it looks pretty close but if you
look at what china russia their
strategic agenda is the international
system they don't want the same thing
the chinese has seen themselves as a
beneficiary of the international system
and putting cause of dissolution of the
soviet leading soviet union is the
biggest tragedy
and the same international system that
china has benefited from from
uh has treated russia as a victim so in
that sense the russian tech
the russian strategy has been one of
strategy of chaos so basically
strengthening russia's bargaining power
and manipulation through a strategy of
chaos but the chinese do not prefer
instability in the international system
because it disrupts what the chinese
want to achieve they do have a shared
common thread which is the united states
and that's also the most salient factor
that has brought beijing and moscow
together but this does not mean that the
two countries are allies and they share
the same ideology same value and same
desired endgame in the international
system
is that how you would explain
their decision to abstain in the
security council vote criticizing the
invasion
well one bottom line of china's policy
towards russia is that china will not
make russia its enemy that is a bottom
line and that is the lesson that china
learned during the cold war music
starting in late 1960s throughout the
1970s and 1980s the chinese biggest
national security concern and threat was
from what was from soviet union
and the using the chinese word because
of the one million troops that soviet
union deployed along the border with
china china was forced to drop its
national development agenda for two
decades in order to deal with this
russian threat
so if you look at china's
china's
behavior pattern there is a pattern that
well it does not
pose itself as a direct opponent
to russia but on issues that china does
not necessarily agree with russia china
will pick a position such as the
abstention that we saw from the u.s
security council this time and this is
also what china did in 2014 china also
abstained as a time when russia and
annexed crimea but on the other hand to
this date china has not yet acknowledged
russian sovereignty over crimea so i
wouldn't uh say this is a one-sided
position i would say this is a balancing
act
do you think that um
we can't expect china to
apply sanctions in the way the west is
trying to do to
russia
but do you think that the
beijing will at any point have the will
and more importantly the capacity
to say to mr putin stop
well i don't see why china would
but there are reasons like diplomatic
embarrassment and there are also things
like uh what china does not want to um
become as well being seen as the
accomplice of russia in this in this
current ukraine crisis
but on the other hand when china looks
at the look at the international system
or international affairs down the road
the chinese question is that will this
in any way improve china's future
outlook in
its relations for example with the
united states and this relations with
the west
and the chinese feel that well if i tell
russia to back off
the end result were the kind and the
consequences for china would be china
will make an enemy out of russia and the
ones that still remain to be china's
enemy so in that sense i think the
chinese calculation is that while they
will continue to muddle through they
will not come out to directly oppose
china oppose russia which is why i argue
the decisive actions and the clear
positions that the international
community desires out of china is
unlikely to unlikely to transpire
might there be um
uh
material or objective pressure on china
ultimately though to take a decision
because of um the economic costs imposed
by sanctions
it said widely that china needs a six
percent growth and that sanctions are
almost certainly going to
uh take a hammer to the world economy so
might that be a reason for china
to as it were get off the fence
well here are two issues one is a
strategic orientation and the other one
is technical or technical calculations
see in this case
given the context of the u.s china great
power competition with a strategic
competition and now the attention being
given to taiwan i think the chinese
strategic orientation is going to be
well we cannot abandon russia and down
the road we probably have to continue to
align our positions with russia because
we do share this
anti-us agenda but it doesn't mean that
on the technical level and the working
level the chinese operations or their
actions cannot be influenced i think
that's where the economic sanctions will
play an important role in shaping the
chinese tactical
operations and tactical positions
which means that for example china has
been the largest trading partner of
russia but if there is a sanctioned
pressure maybe we can bring down the
level of revenue that china is creating
for russia
and
china has been a main financier to
russia in terms of its domestic project
but if the chinese banks are going to
carry severe financial consequences for
their loaning or their financing
decisions to russia then maybe we cannot
completely break it out or completely
eliminate chinese financing to russia
but at least we can curtail its level so
i think that's where the sanctions will
come in but do not expect the sanctions
to completely change china's position on
russia
they say the first casualty of any war
is truth state-controlled media in
russia has been making sure that thought
is being kept front and center in its
coverage clock control i should say
front and center its coverage of the
ukraine conflict on friday a new law was
passed by the russian military
threatening anyone who intentionally
intentionally spreads fake news about
the military with up to 15 years in jail
ruth smith is the ceo of index on
censorship and she joins me now
good morning ruth
what did you make of this new law
good morning trevor i mean i wish i was
surprised about the law but we've seen
a continuing attack in russia on um free
speech and on media freedom
and but what we've seen over the last um
48 hours is unprecedented the voice of
america the bbc
deutsche weller medusa uh radio free
europe which is obviously so relevant
um for um when we're talking about
anything in eastern europe and radio
liberty have all shut up shop
we've got newspapers and media outlets
across russia who have had to stop their
work um some of those who have been so
extraordinarily brave this time last
week we saw the editor of navoya gazetta
um talking about his met
his um
paper and how they were putting the
front cover was a um
was the flag of ukraine they've now
stopped covering what's happening in
ukraine upon fear of prosecution and of
going to prison for 15 years there is no
longer any free media operating
in
uh russia and i would just i mean to the
to the extent that even the scientist
magazine in russia
has um has had to um has been suspended
by the state regulator because seven and
a half thousand scientists signed an
open letter saying that the war was
wrong and there is literally no media
pluralism there is no free media left in
russia
and um i think it's not just legal or
you know law the law that's being used
actually there's some informal
i suppose you could call them methods
being used i just want to show you a
clip of something from the sky news crew
our colleague stuart ramsey uh post uh
did a report yesterday
the ukrainian people are being attacked
from the air from artillery from ground
troops and tanks the debris of this war
litters every street
but the government has warned for days
of russian saboteurs who've infiltrated
the country to bring terror
death squads who are attacking civilians
in their cars as they flee
they do exist
as we found out
well we will be showing more of that on
the channel but uh you can see uh
stewart's report later this evening but
this is something that's affecting
journalists throughout this aren't isn't
it foreign journalists as well as those
domestic to
belarus and russia and ukraine
absolutely i mean we should never be
more grateful for the bravery of the
journalists who are out there and who
are staying
but what they're facing cannot be
underestimated cannot be understated
they are literally their lives are in
their hands at the moment or rather in
the hands of russian forces
it is absolutely appalling freedom of
expression is protected under the un
charter and yet we are seeing a daily
attack on um both on the individuals who
are trying to make sure that people have
news and have information
and on the platforms that um that
provide those news so we've seen you
know social media platforms being
blocked we've seen huge
numbers
of um internet sites being taken down by
the state regulator this is
unprecedented um
in
in a western context really
and just very br and just very briefly
ruth um
uh our own journalists are facing their
own uh
challenges here from uh
oligarchs and rich russians
they are and on um we've seen a series
of um lawsuits that are targeting
journalists and authors they're called
slaps
and on monday evening the economic crime
bill there is an amendment that we've
been working really closely with
politicians on that's led by david davis
and liam burn to stop slaps to make sure
that journalists in the uk are not
subject to attacks uh to lawfare really
um
in a uk legal system we've seen two
really high profile cases in the last
six months catherine belshan and her
book on putin's people unsurprisingly uh
she ended up in court but it nearly
broke her and tom burgess again in the
last 10 days who um who wrote about um
cleture mania uh except autocracy even
so we've seen huge attacks on them and
trying to shut down conversation um in a
european and a british context to make
sure that criticism of what's happening
in russia um can't continue
we have to we have to go to the law to
make sure that we have free speech in
the uk too
ruth thank you so much
you can see stuart ramsey's full report
on that awful incident at 9 30 tonight
here on sky news
well that is it from us uh this is in
fact my last show on the sunday morning
um though if you want some more
punishment you can see me on monday and
tuesday nights uh in upcoming shows but
next sunday the wonderful sophie ridge
is back in her rightful seat and i just
want to say thanks to sophie for giving
me the opportunity
uh thanks to sam coats and the team
gallerian floor politics matters
and it's important that we here
still choose our leaders
others are not so lucky